le vih virus de l'immunodéficience
humaine à ce jour pas de remède
mais depuis les années 80 la médecine à
trouver des moyens d'accompagner les
personnes atteintes et même prémunir
contre l'infection
le premier traitement date de 1987 c'est
la z tes trois lettres et un espoir à
l'époque stopper le sida
clairement ce médicament allonge la
durée de vie des patients
est ce qu'on cherche à obtenir en vérité
c'est une rémission
c'est le terme des gens qui s'occupent
des maladies malignes du chant et de la
maladie s'arrête là zte est une avancée
significative mais n'est pas à la
hauteur des attentes des médecins et des
patients
son efficacité n'est pas systématique et
ces effets secondaires handicap en les
années 90 période d'angoissé
d'impuissance face à la maladie
l'optimisme renaît en 1996 avec la
trithérapie
je prends quatre médicaments dans quatre
ans tilly rétroviraux contre le virus
et puis un cinquième pour éviter les
effets secondaires quand y en a avec la
trithérapie la présence du virus dans le
sang est considérablement diminuer la
charge virale est alors dite
indétectable la personne séropositive ne
peut plus transmettre le vih
on peut envisager le futur dira
peut-être que il va falloir que je
reprenne mon emploi je vais toujours
marché du travail c'est des choses
banales finalement on va retrouver la
halle le bonheur de la banalité au
quotidien en 1998 il est possible d'agir
dans les 48 heures après une prise de
risque c'est ce qu'on appelle le
traitement post exposition un genre de
pilule du lendemain contre le vih agir
après une prise de risque et depuis 2015
intervenir en amont
c'est le principe de la prep la
prophylaxie pré-exposition un an avant
sa mise sur le marché
nathan participé à une étude sur le
traitement c'est des petits cachets
bleus comme ça
depuis 2015 la prep est disponible sur
ordonnance remboursée à 100 % par
l'assurance maladie depuis 2016 donc
j'en prends pas tous les jours ça veut
dire je vais apprendre de façon interne
et tendre quand je sais que mon week end
voilà je t'aime un peu faire la fête un
peu boire et du coup peut-être être
exposé à avoir des rapports à risque
à ce jour le risque de contamination
sous-préfète infime selon les études
ce dispositif prémunit contre le vih
mais pas contre les autres infections
sexuellement transmissibles le meilleur
moyen de se protéger
reste le préservatif
[Musique]